bonjour nouvelle édition du café
politique sur tv fil 78 tous les quinze
jours nous faisons réagir les différents
élus et représentants politiques du
département sur les sujets d'actualité
aussi bien au niveau local qu'au niveau
national voire international dont jour
myriam cormier là vous êtes la
présidente responsable de l'uni sur
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines syndicats
avaient classé classé à droite on va
réagir avec vous sur les différents
sujets de l'actualité des derniers jours
et l'actualité plutôt tragique pour
commencer avec ce nouvel attentat ce qui
ressemble pour l'instant un attentat
même si toutes les confirmations n'ont
pas encore eu lieu qui a touché en deuil
et l'allemagne berlin sur ce marché de
noël avec plus d'une dizaine de victimes
quel sentiment vous avez vous
aujourd'hui en tant que site
responsables politiques est ce qu'il ya
aussi une menace qui pèse est ce que
toutes les mesures sont prises
aujourd'hui pour assurer la sécurité
vous êtes rassuré sur ce point de vue là
c'est tant que responsable politique
trop d'erreurs en tant que citoyenne je
rends hommage à de la tristesse et
surtout de la colère car ce sont des
victimes innocentes qui on était
assassiner lâchement de plus
aucune maison n'a vraiment été prise en
pointe lorsqu'on entend les responsables
politiques allemands
si l'idée mais c'est
des policiers sur sur ce marché de noël
ou peu comme légitimement se poser la
question quand on sait que yann janua
quand on sait que la menace terroriste
est de plus en plus fort moi conseil du
julie that a vu les bombardements les
en ce qui se passe pour la reprise des
villes comme los ou alors ils ont promis
de se venger en europe donc il fallait
prendre des mesures de sécurité beaucoup
plus importante est beaucoup plus forte
qu'en france l'état d'urgence a été
prolongé à ce que c'était une bonne idée
parce qu'il ya des discussions autour de
la prolongation de l'état d'urgence il
faut prolonger l'état d'urgence ma
condition d'y mettre les moyens
lorsqu'on va à alice encore à tous
encore aujourd'hui malgré malgré la
taille du 14 juillet il n'y a pas
suffisamment de sécurité des forces de
l'ordre sur place parce qu on est à
paris on voit certes on voit des
militaires qui à leur mission et qui
sont vraiment là pour nous pour nous
protéger mais on sent encore une menace
et on voit qu'il ya des endroits où il
n'y a pas assez de sécurité et de toute
manière malheureusement c'est un
terroriste de faire une attaque à la
voiture piégée veut faire exploser une
bombe bien
outre il le fera alors une déclaration
soit il faut prendre des mesures de
sécurité efficaces
soit on arrête état d'urgence il
comprend un système de sécurité pour les
français merci aujourd'hui est ce que
par rapport à cette prolongation d'état
d'urgence est tout c'est cette politique
de sécurité qui est très présente
aujourd'hui cette thématique de la
sécurité est ce que ça ne risque pas de
de vampiriser un peu tous les débats
dans le cadre de l'élection
présidentielle aussi est-ce que c'est
pas le risque qu'elles sont elles pas
peur qu'on en fasse trop sur cette
question là et qu'on oublie les autres
préoccupations aussi des citoyens
c'est une thématique qui importent
beaucoup pour les citoyens mais
récemment dans un sondage les citoyens
ont clairement a précisé que les sujets
qui les intéressait le plus c'était
l'action sur le chômage
le travail de la fiscalité la sécurité
n'arrivent et troisième positions donc
ça démontre et quand bien même il est
une menace terroriste
on veut tous être en sécurité le travail
la fiscalité d'emplois seront les thèmes
majeurs pour l'élection présidentielle
de 2017
et puisque vous parlez de l'emploi on va
parler d'eux un autre sujet d'actualité
c'est le smic aussi ce salaire minimum
sur le plan social économie c'est l'un
des événements importants c'est ce
plafonnement puisque il n'y aura pas de
coup de pouce sur la revalorisation
automatique du smic et à une
augmentation seulement de 0 95% sur le
1er janvier 2017 passera neuf euros 67 à
9 euros 76 brut de l'heure pas de coup
de pouce qu'il n'y aura pas eu de coup
de pouce ou tout le quinquennat de de
françois hollande
est ce que c'est c'est justifié parce
que vous trouvez que justement qu'il n'y
ait pas de coup de pouce c'est normal il
aurait fallu un petit coup de pouce sur
le smic il aurait fallu un petit coup de
pouce pour niveau du smic
tout d'abord pour permettre aux ménages
de pouvoir consommer car l'image qu'on
semble de moins en moins et surtout de
leur permettre aussi de pouvoir épargner
et de pouvoir vivre décemment
lorsqu'on voit les coûts alors que les
conditions de vie se dégradent en france
quand on voit qu'il est mêlé aux nuages
et modestes sont de plus en plus dans la
précarité nous a fallu remonter de
manière symbolique le smic à le passer a
pas à dire aux deux
brut de l'heure même quand bien même je
suis plutôt de droite mais il faut aussi
penser aux familles les plus modestes et
les familles les plus précaires qui
aurait bien voulu avoir un réel coup de
pouce et 7 nour valorisation ça vient
d'un groupe et d'économistes qui
conseille le gouvernement et qui
s'affiche tout simplement sur la
consommation des ménages les plus
modestes
ce qui est ridicule pour calculer cette
revalorisation a fallu prendre en compte
que quatre thématiques le coût de la vie
que tout ce qu'ils puissent qui englobe
la vidéo d'une personne ou d'une famille
parce que vous l'avez souligné votre
syndicat est classé à droite et si on
regarde le programme les éléments de
programme pour l'instant de françois
fillon par exemple candidat du centre et
de la droite on est plutôt sur un
programme très très serré très
est rigoureux
est-ce que donc françois fillon derrière
va lui augmenter donner des coups de
pouce c'est pas certain non plus il le
fera mais de manière mesurée mais il ne
veut pas et sait très bien que la
pauvreté a augmenté en france et nous
savons tous a augmenté de 14% ou on voit
bien qu'il ya les chiffres qui sont
assez alarmants mais il fera en sorte ou
deux d'aider les familles les plus
modestes tout en ayant un programme
rigoureux pour permettre un retour à
l'équipe pour les finances publiques
parce qu'on parle de ce programme
justement il est encore en cours
d'élaboration est ce que vous à votre
échelle avec votre syndicat étudiant
vous intervenez d'une manière ou d'une
autre de propositions des suggestions
que vous aimeriez voir porter ce qu on
le sait la jeunesse les étudiants c'est
toujours important dans une campagne
nous intervenons juste sur les questions
pour le point l'école
l'université ce sont des seules
questions sur lesquelles nous sommes
mende et pour le reste chacun est à sa
place il ya des groupes il ya des
spécialistes pour chaque thématique pour
le pour élaborer le programme de 2010 et
bien si on parle des universités
justement résultats aux examens palmarès
2010 est de la réussite au masters qui
montrent de nombreuses inégalités
je vais citer quelques chiffres sur les
114 1491 étudiants inscrits pour la
première fois en master 1ère année en
2013 seulement à la moitié à peine plus
de la moitié ont réussi deux ans plus
tard à obtenir ce diplôme et les
différences sont très nets d'une
université à une autre
ça veut dire quoi que l'autonomie des
universités ce n'était pas une bonne
chose que du coup ça crée de renforcer
des inégalités comment vous analysez ces
différences le tenait la loi sur
l'autonomie des universités et il était
une très bonne chose mais il m'a fallu
que les universités suivent le mouvement
en mettant plus de moyens et en
proposant des plaquettes pédagogique
beaucoup beaucoup plus sûr est beaucoup
plus pédagogiques
lorsqu'on voit les plaquettes dans
certains universités il n'y a rien dit
il ya des disciplines qui sont louables
mais qui ne savent pas qu'on va dire
qu'ils ne servent pas à grand chose sur
le marché du travail va déboucher ou le
marché bloqué derrière justement il
aurait bien fallu l'autonomie très bien
mais il aura fallu avoir ainsi un réel
suivi de la part des présidents
d'université des directeurs d'ufr pour
pouvoir avoir d une pédagogie ce tueur
et pourquoi pas à harmoniser certaines
paquet sur certains programmes de master
en droit en psychologie outre en
médecine on sait très bien que l'âme ou
même programme est identique portugais
en droit parce que ce sont deux
républiques on va priver en connaissance
de cause certaines taxes varient d'une
faculté à l'autre en fonction pour un
même master je ne lui revient pas lui
avoir une assez d'harmonisation et
surtout pas donner plus de moyens
financier et personnel pour pouvoir
aider ses équipes et par rapport à
l'université justement de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines où vous
étudiez quel regard vous avez sur ceux
sur les résultats de cette université
on sait qu'il ya aussi eu récemment
encore un mouvement de grève un peu pour
dénoncer des moyens qui étaient pas
forcément ceux attendus par une partie
du personnel enseignant aujourd'hui
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines a les moyens d'offrir à ses
étudiants de bonnes conditions d'études
de réussir à l'université de versailles
saint quentin en est un très bonne voie
et j'ai une très bonne université
elle se classe 10e dans le palmarès des
universités françaises qui est déjà un
très bon chiffre
de plus il ya quand même une
une pédagogie qui mise en place tout
d'abord on a déjà la chance d'avoir des
enseignants dans n'importe quelle fr qui
sont très proches des étudiants et qui
sert de conseiller au niveau de nos
orientations des cours de plus il ya des
maquettes pédagogiques sont refaites
chaque année par exemple pour la fac de
droit il ya un collège de droit qui est
fait pour les meilleurs étudiants pour
leur permettre d'exceller pour
concurrencer les autres universités
parisiennes c'est une très bonne chose
mais il est aussi tout un toutes les
langues de tutorat pour les étudiants
qui sont moyens mais qui leur permettra
de réussir dès la première année
de plus tout est fait pour la réussite
des étudiants en université de verser 50
ans que ce soit de la part des
enseignants comme la part du personnel
administratif qui facilite pas mal de
choses pour les faux pour les options
vous parlez de l'intervention de l'ue ni
sur le programme l'élaboration du
programme du candidat françois fillon
sur la partie l'université et du
question quelle est la priorité
aujourd'hui sur l'éducation sur les dix
universités qu'est-ce qu'il faut changer
la mise en place de la sélection à
l'université elle va quitter dès
l'entrée à l'université dès la première
année oui parce que ça nous évitera des
filières boucher commanderont en
psychologie on se retrouve avec des
amphithéâtres de 500 600 personnes et
qui
au bout de deux trois semaines après il
ya plus de la moitié qui a déserté les
bancs de l'université
ce qui va montrer un fort taux d'échec
si ces étudiants sont orientés des
départs après leur bac dans une filière
où ils sont sûrs de réussir filière
bts licence professionnelle dix ans le
masters ou autre ça sera beaucoup plus
impôts ces étudiants à la fois et ne
perdons pas une année pour les mrc des
servitra des engorgements dans les
amphithéâtres et
des cours parfois qu'ils sont
impossible à tenir quand c'est 600
personnes dans un ampli cas de 400
personnes ce qui est dommageable à la
fois pour l'enseignant mais aussi pour
les étudiants mais en plus avoir des
étudiants qui sont rendus dès le départ
ça leur permet pas d'être sûr d'avoir un
bon cv et
de trouver un travail assez rapidement
mais alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait des
étudiants qui sortent du lycée une fois
qu'ils ont leur bac c'est toutes les
filières sont très sélectives comme on
les accompagne il faut aussi une
politique d'accompagnement de meilleure
orientation des lycées dès le lycée par
exemple en mettant en place ces des
cours d'initiation découverte pour ces
étudiants s'ils veulent aller
s'ils veulent aller par exemple en
médecine en droit en psychologie en
lettres car montrer ce qu'on attend
d'eux à l'université parce qu'on a quand
on a eu au lycée né dans un moteur de
coco on a tout le temps tous les
enseignants qui sont derrière nous pour
nous dire vous allez faire ça pour tel
jour à telle à telle date
alors qu'à l'université on prend notre
cour et on sait qu'on a des thés des
affaires on a des
on a des devoirs des échéances mais
c'est nous qui nous débrouillons au
niveau du planning j on apprend aux et
aux jeunes lycéens dès le départ voilà
vous allez devoir faire ça pour apte à
l'échéance organisez vous sur votre
temps de travail voilà ce qu'on attend
de vous en fac de lettres en fac de
droit en médecine justement ça va leur
apprendre l'autonomie mais en plus à
savoir ce qu'ils veulent faire
exactement
on va continuer à regarder un petit peu
ce qui s'est passé du côté de
l'actualité ces derniers jours et on va
parler d'eux pas vraiment de transport
mais plutôt pollution même si les deux
thématiques sont liés et ça me permettra
aussi de souligner qu' aujourd'hui vous
cette seule pour cette mission du café
politique mais les autres invités
sollicité représentants de nouvelle
donne ou encore de la france insoumise
de jean luc mélenchon une quelques
petits soucis de transport est ce qui
explique aujourd'hui qui ne sont pas
présents pour revenir donc à cette
thématique de la pollution il ya eu la
mise en place de la circulation alternée
régulièrement est-ce que j'ai ça vous
trouvez que c'est une bonne solution est
ce que les énergies alternatives sont
suffisamment encouragez vous en tant que
jeune également comment vous percevez ce
problème là vous êtes j'imagine
sensibiliser à ça ce que vous faites
attention sur vos modes de déplacement
par rapport à la pollution
badescu d'abord je privilégie les
transports en commun à la voiture ce qui
est beaucoup plus simple
voilà exactement mais après la
circulation alternée n'ya une forme
d'hypocrisie qui y règne
il ya des voitures ultra polluantes on
va dire de grosses cylindrées de grandes
marques de marque allemande par exemple
tu pêches qui peuvent circuler alors
qu'elle pollue beaucoup donc justement
il faudra trouver une alternative
vignette qu'une système de vignettes qui
sera mis en place à partir de la
mi-janvier sur paris et la grande
couronne où il y aura justement cette
incidence de en fonction du cylindre et
de la marque de pollution l'impact sur
le sur l'environnement quand on regarde
quand on écoute les informations c'est
laid
un policier il
eux-mêmes que
la mise en place de la circulation
alternée ne peut pas être respecté par
tous car en pas le temps de vérifier
toutes les cac donc justement y aura
tout le temps des personnes qui vont
conduire ce jour là et après voudrait
aussi inciter à ce que le gouvernement
mette en place un système pour permettre
aux ménages les plus modestes pour vos
faisant des voitures diesel qui polluent
beaucoup et enfin maître de chant eva
une sorte de prime à la casse pour leur
permettre de louga ya quelques années
sous nicolas sarkozy il fallait
président hu nicolas sarkozy est
justement de leur permettre de changer
de voiture avec une aide du gouvernement
ça leur permettrait leur permettrait à
la fois notre nouvelle voiture mais en
plus de faire une action écologique on
parle de pollution parler des programmes
politiques on a quand même le sentiment
que l'environnement n'est pas la
priorité des politiques aujourd'hui dans
les débats que ce soit à droite ou à
gauche on en parle assez peu de
l'environnement aujourd'hui de
l'environnement et leurs robes ce sont
en général les deux thématiques plutôt
absente des discussions politiques à ce
moment pourtant à droite on en parle
beaucoup il raconte en parle pas mal ce
qu'il ya pas mal de nos tests de
thématiques comme savez sur les
frontières sûres
le dumping social qui sont des
thématiques qui nous tiennent à coeur
à droite après l'environnement on en
parle dans les yeux durant la primeur on
a on en parle encore et
tout sera fait pour mettre un programme
écologique pour proposer ce programme
écologique ce volet écologique dans le
programme du candidat de la droite et du
centre françois fillon même si la droite
ya d'autres candidats qui depuis se
manifestant notamment citer aussi henri
guaino qui m'a bien y aller député des
yvelines et qui pourraient se présenter
en dehors de tout ça d'ailleurs fait
parenthèse quel regard vous portez sur
ces candidats qui souhaitent se
présenter hors primaire et qui
appartiennent à la famille votre belle
famille politique
c'est vraiment dommage car s'il aurait
voulu
à apporter leurs idées leurs programmes
comme henri guaino michèle alliot marie
il aurait dû faire dans leur voie durant
la primaire certains élus
réputé comme jacques myard jean frédéric
poisson quand bien même ce sont des
candidats pas très très connu du grand
public
on colle ça partait leur voix
jean frédéric poisson nuit était
automatiquement
une partition trouvée automatiquement se
présenter mais j'ai bien vu comme
jacques myard a mais fait il l'a dépassé
dans toute la france pour faire des ces
idées s'était passé était à la bo était
au touquet et justement quand même il a
fait y avoir toutes ces signatures mais
il a réussi quand même à faire entendre
sa voix et ses idées et sa faim
candidats
sont venues l'écouter pour représenter
la nation mais aussi l'écouté la
primaire aujourd'hui c'est l'actualité
de la gauche
pensez quoi de cette primaire à gauche
on se croirait dans une pièce de théâtre
tout simplement
n'allez pas dire l'inversé j'imaginais
pas l'un vers ce cas on va une
une forme de bataille de l'eau j'ai eu
cette bataille d'égos malgré tout à
droite en outre nicolas sarkozy juppé
françois fumée s'était moins bien car le
mode horde à la fin c'était une unité et
on savait dès le départ nous avons dit
pas requise peu importe le gagnant nous
serons tous rassemblés derrière lui pour
le prg a gagné en mai 2017 et pas gagner
tous nos candidats en juin 2017
aulas on assiste avec la primaire de la
gauche à une forme de déliquescence
d'une parti socialiste car on voit que
jean christophe cambadélis favorise
certaines candidatures et passé et pas
d'autres l'ol ne sont pas toujours très
claires exactement quand on voit que
gérard filoche ou paul la route route de
nouvelles donnes ont été floués pour
présenter leur candidature à la primaire
alors qu'ils avaient les signatures
nécessaires pour se présenter et qui
partent demandé à emmanuel macron qui se
dit par système tient alors qu'il en est
mais l'enjeu aussi y participer même
genre que l'argent qui refuse aussi de
participer de participer à cette
primaire pour le parent de loyauté c'est
ce qu'il avait dit
alors que manuel makhouki ni militant ps
niveau du martyr et est invité
cordialement participé d'une forme
d'injustice de signature à des vitesses
pour terminer cette cette édition du
café politique je vais vous demander ce
que vous vous retenez d'actualité de ces
derniers jours est ce qui vous a marqué
le plus que ce soit sur un plan local ou
international ya un sujet dont on n'a
pas parlé
c'est aussi à l'est pas voilà aussi un
des sujets importants d'actualité mais
qu'est ce que vous retenez qu'est ce qui
est important pour vous dans l'actualité
actuellement
il ya deux sujets qui m'importe c'est à
la fois ce qui se passe en syrie en irak
la question des suites garde de jour en
jour et ce qui est vraiment triste et
l'attentât de berlin qui qui marque
encore les esprits qui nous et qui nous
oblige à être plus vigilants et qui va
obliger les publics à prendre des
mesures nécessaires pour protéger tous
les citoyens
merci d'être venus participer merci à
café politique et prochaine édition au
mois de janvier très bonnes fêtes de fin
d'année à tous et à toutes
on se retrouve très bientôt sur
téléphiles
[Musique]